highly competitive and at the same time
insecure world and I would like to draw
your attention one more time to an art
to the article which was published today
in rhesus egg as it was written by the
Russian Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
and titled
European neighbors Russia EU 30-years
loan relations it studies a major
historic landmarks and prospects of
Russia EU relations we think that this
article will be of use to everyone
including our EU colleagues of those who
sincerely want our Eurasian continent
from Lisbon to Vladivostok to remain
peaceful secure and prosperous we also
have topics linked with the you European
continent and the common European space
and with the European organizations in
particular I would like to comment on
the Venice Commission of the Council of
Europe conclusion on the Ukrainian law
and provision of the functioning of the
Ukrainian language as the state language
on the 7th to 8th December on during the
plenary meeting on the European
Commission for democracy through
loneliness Commission concluded
concluded only the law of provision of
the function in the European European
language at the state language and the
experts underline that this law runs
contrary to the international
international commitments of the EU it
says that it it discriminates at twice
the Russian language in politics
Education and Culture so the demands to
publish scientific words works on
Ukrainian and in English and in other EU
official languages in the opinion of the
expert are unjustified and infringe upon
the freedom of expression and is
expressing the same of the band to hold
cultural and entertainment events in
Russian great the experts criticized on
the installation of the Ombudsman on the
protecting these states language and on
the mechanisms of complaints and
administrative fines because it is
unknown on what's legal basis this
Ombudsman will impose sanctions the
experts have focused on the fact that
the language policy pursued by Ukraine
is the source of constant tensions that
prevent peace and harmony in this regard
Kiev is recommended to review its law
from the point of view of its
international commitments and to cancel
differentiate its regime can of
regarding national minorities rights and
to think of canceling sanction
mechanisms of complaints or at least
limits its usage and to adopt a law on
national minorities that would respect
the interests of all groups of
population we think that this conclusion
is objective and we hope that Ukrainian
authorities will listen to the opinion
of this important international European
Authority I cannot be touch upon a very
important topic that is linked with the
life of the European continent Ukraine
over the last years we took note of the
incidents when Russian journalists have
been denied entry into Ukraine over the
last approximately 10 days Ukrainian
authorities three times denied entry
into the country to the an TV channel
reporters and twice it was said that
journalists did not confirm the purpose
of their visit that's why they were
denied of entry and one journalist was
denied of entry because she had visited
Crimea in 2016 apart from that on the
13th of December a camera crew of Swiss
da TV channel was detained Department
from key if they were fined for the fact
that they allegedly illegally were
filming during the passport control
procedure on the 11th of December
and after a few days they were denied of
entry into Ukraine for three years it's
noteworthy that all those incidents
happened after the 9th of December when
there was a press conference held after
the normative four summit the when
president of Ukraine Vladimir slansky
publicly invited Russian journalists to
visit Ukraine in order to follow and
impartially cover processes taking part
in the country you know that even before
this press conference we've heard a lot
of interesting facts from Kiev over the
last few months we also heard that as
the Ukrainian president was trying to
persuade everyone that he is not a fool
and we consulted the dictionary what
that does that means it means loser a
dilettante a victim of criminals etc etc
we would like to believe that this is
not the case and the Ukrainian president
in his current position will hold his
word keep his promise and will provide
free access to all journalists into the
territory of Ukraine and it was his
initiative if we talk about the 9th of
December it wasn't the demands from the
Russian journalists but it was
accusations made by him which can really
be reduced to the fact that they are
able to prefer to provide information
from the studio but they are unable to
come and cover the events taken on that
place on the ground and immediately
after these words Russian journalists
decided to accept this invitation and
proposition
and you see the result and I've already
told you what happens afterwards we
understand that it will be very
difficult for the Ukrainian president to
keep his promise given the situation in
the country and we call on the relevant
international structures and NGOs above
all mr. de zere OSC representative on
freedom of the media to assist mr.
zalanski in his endeavor let's proceed
to the other topics Latin America and
Venezuela situation in Venezuela and
around it
speaking of Venezuela we have noted on
numerous occasions the counterproductive
and inhumane unilateral sanctions that
were imposed against the country we
underlined that such restrictions
negatively affect social humanitarian
situation create the artificial deficit
of food and medicine on the whole market
this is a fact and cannot be denied
referring to some political goals and
objectives which are issued by the
states that impose such restrictions
from our part we are doing our best in
order to support friendly Venezuelan
people at this difficult period and in
this regard we have a positive views
very constructive once about the very
constructive step last week when is well
received the first shipment of 220
200,000 packs of medications containing
insulin produced by the russian company
Guerra forum is not a one-time shipment
during the 2019 2020 we are planning to
send more than 5 million packs of this
medications that will satisfy the needs
of for more than 400,000 citizens of
Venezuelans with diabetes the shipments
will be sent every month in the future
we will send more different types of
medications moreover the Russian
companies committed to send end products
to Venezuela as well as contribute to
the process of training and highly
qualified specialists in the medicine
field of Venezuela and all
to ensure the transfer of technologies
of packaging of the insulin medications
we think that this is a concrete example
of constructive bilateral cooperation
aimed at improving humanitarian
situation in Venezuela
unfortunately these good news are
sometimes put on the back burner burner
by Washington who constantly repeats
threatening about the use of force
against the legitimate even as well in
government recently we have heard the
words of the State Department Special
Representative mr. Abrams he said that
the US administration does not dismiss
the opportunity to intervene in
Venezuela and to use other violent
options we get the impression that
Washington cannot come up with something
completely new their creativity is in
crisis there is a good option how about
you start restoring something that you
were trying to destroy for the last a
couple of years and we are committed we
are convinced that those who use this
pressure mechanisms play themselves into
a corner which will be very difficult to
avoid without losing one's face and
recent developments showed the failure
of the one Godot project who is mired in
high-profile corruption scandals and he
continues to pursue the policy of
provocations recently we've learned
about the unmasked conspiracy of his
fellow party members to attack to
military garnish Garrison's in the
Venezuelan state of sucre in order to
capture Arsenal's and to provoke further
arms clashes by the way we can ask
Washington this question whether this
opposition is democratic one whether we
can consider this deposition a
democratic one
because this term was introduced by the
western side and they say that their
actions are proportional proportional
whether these actions are proportional
is doubtful we think it's high time for
caracas opponent to come to terms with
the objective reality of in israel has
only one head of state nicolas maduro
the president of the country and
compromise decisions are possible only
via national dialogue which starts to
bear achievements and we confirmed that
we are ready to contribute to the
intervenors waylynn negotiations to the
extent desired by the Venezuelans and we
stand in support of the international
law UN Charter goals and principles
including non interference into the
internal affairs of the dissident states
in other region and over the last week
it was widely discussed I'm talking
about the thesis proposed by the US
administration of the negative role of
Russia in Libyan settlement we had a lot
of statements over the last a week over
the last week and so we focused continue
to focus on the situation in Libya it
was discussed in Washington by Russian
Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov and u.s.
state secretary mister of compel Russian
position remains this same with stand
for halt in all warfare and for
inclusive political interlab in dialogue
and this is the only way to settle this
conflict in this context Russia is ready
to contribute to the process because we
have contacts with all current political
forces in Libya at the same time
Washington
sends different signals in particular
state US state secretariat declared
yesterday that US is ready to work with
our country on the Libyan settlement
at the same time we received the
information from the Capitol Hill about
the elaboration of a draft law act on
stabilizing situation in Libya it
provides imposing sanctions against
Moscow for allegedly military presence
Russian military presence in Libya they
want to accuse Moscow of military
intervention that has become the main
dis table isin factor in Libya it's a
very interest in how American
legislators qualify illegitimate
military presence of the US troops in
Syria for example or reckless actions of
the previous US administration on the
Libyan track in particular unfortunately
these very aggressive steps we can use
other words to describe the u.s. actions
they are impossible to justify their
illogical etc etc but these actions are
the current feature of the u.s. policy
it was said during the press conference
during his interview the Russian Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov he said that we
are used to these actions we know how to
react to them so let's use this very
example and let's find out
what apart from progress from developing
anti-russian sentiments drives the u.s.
legislatures
and we should note that the the US
legislators don't have enough expertise
to have the objective objective view of
the world and so we will address the
expert community they are expected to
provide expert opinion they use the
system of grants finance and system
support system they concentrate on a
certain topic they have an experience in
this very field so let's take a look who
who is the trend setter for in terms of
the US legislation legislators opinion
on the Syrian issue and regarding the
bill that I've mentioned is very logical
to call from the US administration to
put an end to Russia's air reckless
actions in Libya this is a quote in the
report by a ban fishman an authoritative
expert who specializes in the Middle
East affairs so we took note of his
biography this is a person who is deeply
engaged in these processes but it's
enough to just look at his biography to
learn that he's very engaged and
according to his official biography on
the Washington web on the website during
the second presidency of Obama he
occupied a position very it's very
important director Foley in the National
Council on security u.s. Council of
security when he where he supported
Libyan Revolution so this is a person
was engaged in forming and implementing
cynical and known and unsubstantiated
the policy of the United States during
the Arab Spring this is the person that
doing that paying comments now and the
fact that be developed in this region
and the consequences are coming to the
European continent and Italy knows very
well about this so this is a the person
who was implementing that concept and
nowadays using his abilities of an
expert he's forming a public opinion of
the United States trying to find the
guilty so this is a magical logic so
this is the crisis that came as a
catalyst of the conflict which has been
discussed during the Arobin conference
on this track this provoked outbreak of
violence in Africa this was a thing an
adventure that can mislead the internal
audience and the public opinion in
general that trying to shift the
attention from the fundamental errors
that are being made in there in internal
affairs so these are the signals given
by the United States when discussing
other tracks and to trying trying
although we're trying to overcome the
difficulties in our bilateral relations
we seen the attempts to we try to state
new formats of our cooperation about the
United States disregarded our attempts
to hope that the situation could be
changed another interesting example on
how the experts opinion is being formed
today that is a guiding on this yes
decision-making
and it influences the opinion of the
voters we've taken note on the statement
made by but in an interview of the
former commander-in-chief of the Allied
NATO forces Wesley Clark he is well
aware with the situation in the Balkan
states and he deems that Russia uses the
Balkans as region in its own interests
trying almost to bribe the local
politicians is here a person who could
talk about this
you shouldn't blame us in the facts you
are engaged in so Wesley Clark should
speak about what remuneration he got
from Kosovars from separation of the
region from Serbia and the retired
military officer is in the management of
water for the Canadian energy combat
dvdt what is interesting about this
company and about his position that it
company got the right from Pristina to
developing their own resources in the
third country country that part of the
territory of Kosovo and we speak about
lignite deputies he is also connected to
with the firm of Germany reality which
is engaging in removing them scrap metal
out of other country it is a very
interesting story and protects for
investigation as for the interrelation
between these facts and the forming of
the public opinion so maybe the orders
were given to von Kosovo and the region
maybe for getting beneficial contracts
this is a question which is very
interesting and we should look for the
answer when someone is speaking about
some self-interest so the answer should
be the answer to the question should be
addressed should be given by these
people who are talking about this and
there are pretext to accuse anybody of
the smell corrupt games and political
campaigns so this is the fact I'd like
to draw your attention and the attention
of our compatriots of our tourists who
come to India because recently in the
the Indian states of Assam ours Bengali
Tripura Arunachal Pradesh Meghalaya and
Mizoram a son has seen protest and
demonstration against demanding other
law on the citizenship that led to loss
of human lives and caused the injuries
among the civilians and also this
disruption disruption in the work about
the road and air transportation and also
to the failures of communications and
internet rational citizens who were
staying in India or planning to come to
the country I visited they should be
cautious and abstain from going into
mass basis of mass gathering or visiting
they're protesting near regions and we
advise you to follow all the events on
the media resources of the ministry and
the mobile app the relationship
emotional foreign assistance and I hope
that additional information will be
given further on if you have any
questions please ask them
oh no Senora Moscow about coup the
Virginia side has declared that are many
I refused to exchange a detained persons
according the principle all for all and
some months ago mr. Lavrov highlighted
that Russia has supported the search for
much of exchanges and why do this why
are the other problems in that approach
and what is the stance of Moscow have
already repeatedly spoken on the topic
and this topic has been discussed during
the talks this topic was highlighted
during the meeting in Moscow between the
ministries of Foreign Affairs of
Azerbaijan Armenia in Russia or with the
co-chairs of the means group and the
participants agreed on taking measures
to give access to the families of all
the people detained in by the sides and
as you know with the help of the
rescuers in a June of this year the
citizen of a pattern and the citizen
many near returned to their home so this
is a very important step and we are also
taking steps on other prisoners there
was a controversial information on the
one side Russian government is
allocating their funds on implementing
the in our program to elevate the
applied about the most suffering arena
provinces but at the same time the
Russian our mission is pretending it to
a block of the budget being discussed at
the end
regarding the crime criminal the
military crimes
we assist Syria directly and through the
relevant - mechanism all for the end
at the same time we have a position that
you've already pronounced that he
already highlighted and I don't see any
contradictions in that regard
good afternoon Edgar chesnic of
consumers quebrada last week the turkish
President Erdogan initiated altitude to
declare their genocide against the
original population in the in the United
States as I think you have given not
precise information and I believe for
that it was their position of the
Turkish site to the lawmakers of the
United States and we believe that every
state has a right to pursue its own
policy and to manifest its interests and
if you want to remember what the
migrants did to the Indians we can share
the relevant information with you and it
will be our next step
yes please
many of lady Madonna I will let myself
to oppose you a theoretical and a big
future oriented question the last of
developments in Latin America especially
in Bolivia they show the external
interference and there was a coup d'etat
and also attempts of Kurata in Venezuela
so maybe this direct interference can be
regarded as subjects for the analysis
with the framework of the UN in order to
take necessary measures against to these
countries because this is an established
practice they a question that you asked
this is irrelevant for the external
policy foreign policy for the countries
of the region and you know that we have
always advocated the principles of
non-interference and to the principles
of the charter at the end and we confirm
our stance also in our approaches to
calibrated specifically solutions of the
General Assembly and to more general
documents and we try to give the contact
the attitude the contents of saturate
the contact content of this resolution
with our attitudes and maybe we can
elaborate an attitude without submitting
your the resolution to the General
Assembly on the prevention of the
external interference or using of
resources of some regions in non legal
methods not taken into account of the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
those countries so this is a time of
return to the colonialism if the
countries of the region would think
about the elaboration of such resolution
within the framework of the UN General
as General Assembly many countries could
take part in this work as you said that
this is a question theoretical and area
a future-oriented i havenít been omitted
myself to give the relevant answer i saw
here a news about the extreme east of
the country and about the detainment of
the Japanese vessels or what are the
conditions and of the detainment and
when this situation will be resolved yes
sorry to say the things that you
mentioned really happened according to
the information that we got from the
border a service of the Federal Security
Service of Russia and according to the
representatives of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs in Euro so Hollings come
the 17th of December the result of the
operation by the rational
Border Services who checked the Japanese
vessels that was were fishing octopus in
near self corals on the basis of the
agreements on cooperation in the marine
living resources
the five of them were revealed to heaven
consistencies with the catch volumes and
of the data in the fishing logs so again
the name of these vessels we speak about
a small vessels halloumi morrow number
53 say samara number 62 Oh tomorrow
number 38
Oh maitake morrow number 45 55 and from
attack Amon number 53 I hope I have
given all the names in a right way in
the primary order I can say that the
overfishing is calculated by several
tons and put into humanitarian reasons a
Russian border the service employees
gave generation sir to the crew we also
we also provided necessary food fuel and
clothes because among the crew members
of the two vessels there are people
suffering from a serious diseases and we
also take this into account and the
relevance of medications should be
provided and the and I say I would like
to say that the agreement is in place
for 20 years and this its implementation
is being accompanied by such violations
and we hope for and urge the Japanese
side to take effective measures such
employment it in a press mistakenly hope
after the victory of Boris Johnson in
the elections in Great Britain the
report has been approved that would be
published next year on the Russian
mandolin and how do you assess the
activities of the British air
colleagues enter what you'd expect after
the elections that has taken place we
believe that it's a report of a
sovereign state this is their wish to
publish or to elaborate on the topic but
many materials of data being cited by
our colleagues or many leaked many
leakages that are also being published
maybe we should not comment on that
because this is just would generate a
way for from misinformation of her fake
news and it looks more like information
campaigns rather than anything else and
we'll always welcome to the
publication's of the information based
on facts and this is a former general
comment and specifically I'd like to say
that it will depend on the decision made
by some but made by the state the
expectations of Moscow are obvious and
the developments that are been take
taken place of the year they should be
in the legal framework and we have
already announced our expectations and
have published them through special
channels and we hope that this
investigation would be in the legal
framework could you turn on the mic
turn on the mic do you know that to the
interpol was searching for him maybe
could be more precise on in your
question
so the russia is a member of the
interpol how could you fail to know that
they were searching for a person i'm not
engaged in the Interpol matters i can
only specify double check on who
declared this and who was in charge
every university agency i recently the
european parliament passed a resolution
criticizing the illegal actions of the
russian side against the lithuanian
judges prosecutors and investigators who
participated in making the decisions
regarding the events of the 13th of
january 1991 in vilnius and Interpol was
asked to ignore the corresponding quiz
questions on the part of russia
well you know we try to distend she ate
ourselves as possible regarding the
activity of the european parliament but
as far as this topic is concerned not
the external part of it but it's just on
the whole the russian approaches the
following the investigation commission
of our country last july started an
criminal investigation into the
officials of the general Prosecutor's
Office of the Republic of Lithuania
involving clearly innocent for this
criminal responsibility regarding this
fabricated case of 13th of January 1991
the persecution of her email which has
been constantly coming to the on Gennady
one of and other Soviet military men is
carried out by Vilnius against all the
norms of international law and him
right what are we talking about
they were missing both in Soviet and
Lithuanian legislation in year crimes
like that and this goes against the
fundamental principle that there can be
no punishment without a crime and in
invisibility of giving legal lower
retrospective force and contemporary
Lithuania in this respect contradicts in
its actions the legal foundations and I
would like to remind you that the
country did not exist at the moment of
those events of Vilnius in January 1991
and the Lithuania gained its official
international recognition only in
September 1991 including by the European
states the parliamentarians of which
voted for this resolution of the
European Parliament unfortunately they
did not take this into consideration at
all and we cannot talk about any
intervention in Lithuania internal
affairs it's just absurd because in
January 1991 it was still part of the
USSR and everything happened in Vilnius
was an internal affair of the USSR I
also see those accusations of aggression
which is freely at the level of some
novel because this basically says that
USSR attacked itself we should note that
Russian investigation does not influence
the state of the Lithuanian persons in
questions they are carrying out of their
duties
we don't see this in our evaluations of
the actions of the Athenian officials
but they should probably focus rather on
such European various as the primacy of
law and human rights so that they would
be really involved in legalizing some
politicized persecution of Russian
citizens in Lithuania and on the whole
try to pressurize the Russian justice
system and call on the states to violate
their international obligations
Russia today Maradona good afternoon as
you know on 24th of December in
Montenegro the Parliament will be
studying the draft law on the freedom of
religion and belief beliefs and the
legal situation of religious communities
in Montenegro which in that country has
caused some ambivalent reactions how can
you comment on that I would just like to
say that we're talking about a law of a
sovereign state it and it's the
prerogative of the country of its people
and we're categorically against any kind
of intervention in internal affairs and
if we talk about the actual procedure of
studying this draft law or if we talk
rather about the contents the idea
behind it it can actually seriously
affect the interest of the Montenegro
literally metropolitan CEO of the
servant of the church and this includes
the property rights towards religious
facilities and objects and if we focus
on this part of your question then this
topic is outside national realm and
touches upon the question of unity and
solidarity of the Orthodox Christian
world the principles that it took
centuries to create and so we are
convinced that it's important and simply
necessary to keep up with the legal
foundations of the canonical Orthodox
Church and respect the rights of the
religious people we often comment on the
religious topics with a great respect
for the norms of various international
legal instruments in taking into
consideration that we talk about
religions etc but this topic is highly
politicized has been highly politicized
over the last several years on the part
of the executive power representatives
of the Western countries and we have to
comment on it not from the point of view
of our evaluation of the actual topic of
Orthodox Christianity or any other
religions but rather from the point of
view how there are interventions into
the religious affairs and how it is done
rather abruptly by the executive power
and not just executive branch of power
but in any case by officials of various
countries speaking of which this is
something that can be said about the
situation and events in the religious
life of Ukraine when we saw those
actions we all know that pretty much
shook the International Orthodox
Christian society and community and
affected the life of the society and the
lives of specific citizens in particular
so I think this is a rather tragic
example and it's in everyone's interest
to avoid recurrence of such cases yes
please
good afternoon they stink of Qasim madam
Zohra bah how does Russia evaluate the
project of sanctions against Turkey for
purchasing it as 400 approved by the
international community
we are against any kind of sanctions
which have not been verified and
legalized through corresponding bodies
of the UN Security Council the
unilateral sanctions as far as we see it
are illegitimate and pressure that is
exerted on countries using the mechanism
of sanctions goes against the norms of
international relations which are
established in a large number of
international legal documents bilateral
and those basis this foundations you
know I already just said bases and
foundations cannot come up with any
other word baby surf is the foundation
for international structures we are
categorically against any kind of
sanctions pressure and using sanction
instruments be it financial system
economics humanitarian sphere etc etc
for resolving the own contradictions and
any other kind of problems with
countries yes please madam zakharov the
first words of incidence key regarding
Russian journalists already are rather
different from that active his actions
and can you expect that the actions of
Ukraine regarding Normandy for will also
be different and to or would you argue
this ban in international on
international platforms is Ministry of
ready to use diplomatic channels for
what
well diplomatic channels something which
you cannot use to argue a decision
diplomatic challenge I used to
communicate a point of view to express I
don't know your view evaluation or
transmit your requests but in this case
we're talking about
a certain sphere providing or denying
entry to Ukraine
however paradoxical it is is not
regulated by any kind of lower any
provision any illegal act that would be
in force on its territory we're talking
about an instruction on the part of the
Security Council of Ukraine which makes
it possible to deny people entry into
the country that's all there is so any
country has its legal and legally based
on some document procedure which has
been elaborated adopted approved for
entry or foreign journalists for example
there are countries where journalists
can come without visas without any
permits
without any special documents without
any formalities and actually as far as I
think Ukraine used to be a state like
that but then something happened to it
on its way towards European values and
it started carrying out this factual
singer aggression of journalists without
any legal foundation for it
so we see something which is by default
outside the legal framework and it's
carrying out through some force this
decision are implemented like that and
as far as Ukraine's fulfilment of its
international obligations is concerned
we work through international bodies
which in their turn and it would be
applicable what you said to argue for
making them comply with their obligation
what Kiev signed the resolutions and
declarations it took party in on its
national state
in its national state capacity do you
have any other questions if none then
we'll see you next time
you